en este vídeo quiero que quede muy claro
y que analicemos cuál es la diferencia
entre una ventaja absoluta y una ventaja
comparativa y bueno nosotros habíamos
visto en el vídeo pasado cuál era una
ventaja comparativa lo que estuvimos
viendo en el vídeo pasados que gaby
tienen una ventaja comparativa en platos
a comparación de alfredo porque ella
obtenía con un tercio de taza un plato
mientras que alfredo tiene un plato por
tres tazas y esto le daba a gabi una
ventaja comparativa en platos a
comparación de alfredo mientras tanto
también habíamos visto que alfredo tenía
una ventaja comparativa pero él en tazas
porque él obtenía una taza por un tercio
de plato mientras que gaby obtenía una
taza por tres platos y esto hacía que
alfredo obtuviera una ventaja
comparativa en tasas a comparación de
gabi y fue por este motivo que alfredo
le convenía a especialistas en tasas
mientras que a gabi le convenía
especializarse en platos y así comerciar
ahora no hay que confundir esta ventaja
con la ventaja absoluta con la ventaja
absoluta nos referimos a obtener la
ventaja sobre un producto es decir ser
más productivo en ese producto teniendo
las mismas entradas
que si yo te doy esta gráfica de la
izquierda no podemos saber cuántos
trabajadores están con alfredo o con
gavin o cuántas entradas están
utilizando para producir las tazas o los
platos y por lo tanto no hay forma de
hablar de una ventaja absoluta ahora
bien si hablamos de que tienen los
mismos trabajadores y las mismas
entradas y nos fijamos por ejemplo en
gavín si podemos decir que entonces gabi
tiene una ventaja absoluta en platos a
comparación de alfredo pues estaríamos
tomando las mismas entradas y de manera
análoga para alfredo si el tren tiene
las mismas entradas que está gaby
entonces él tendrá una ventaja absoluta
en tazas eso sí hay que tener mucho
cuidado
recuerdan que tenemos que fijarnos en
las entradas porque por ejemplo si
alfredo necesitas 100 trabajadores para
obtener estas 30 tazas mientras que si
gavi necesita un solo trabajador para
obtener estas 10 tazas entonces la
ventaja absoluta sería para gaby 10 más
vamos a verlo con un nuevo ejemplo en
este ejemplo voy a suponer que alfredo
logró aumentar su productividad y además
alfredo va a tener una ventaja
comparativa mayor en los dos productos a
comparación de gabi
padre de este ejemplo que vamos a ver es
que a pesar de su ventaja comparativa
que va a tener alfredo tanto gaby como
alfredo van a necesitar especializarse y
comerciar en esta gráfica aquí tenemos
el eje de lasieso el eje de las tasas y
necesito también mi eje de dos platos
que es este de aquí este es mi eje de
dos platos y también vamos a enumerar lo
igual que la vez pasada entonces aquí
tengo las tasas aquí tengo los platos y
aquí voy a tener diez veinte platos 30
platos y 40 platos y aquí van a ser 10
tazas 20 tazas 30 tazas y 40 tazas y
vamos a suponer que gaby tienen la misma
producción que la vez pasada es decir si
gastaba todo su tiempo podría producir
10 tazas y si gastaba también todo su
tiempo puede producir 30 platos se
acuerdan y el que aumentó su producción
fue alfredo y alfredo tuvo un aumento en
su producción enorme ahora tiene un 40
40 es decir si gasta todo su tiempo va a
obtener 40 tazas y también si gasta todo
su tiempo va a obtener 40 platos
creció bastante su producción y bueno
ahora sí que ya tenemos las dos rectas
dibujadas tenemos los dos papeles tanto
para gaby como para el freno y si se dan
cuenta al trono tiene una mayor ventaja
absoluta si tienen las mismas entradas
ojos y tienen las mismas entradas que
gaby porque él produce 40 tazas mientras
que gaby solamente produce 10 y él
produce también 40 platos mientras que
gaby produce solamente 30 en la misma
cantidad de tiempo por lo tanto tiene
una ventaja comparativa y una ventaja
absoluta tanto en tasas como en platos
así que para sacar los costos de
oportunidad de hacerlo de manera más
específica vamos a escribirlo aquí así
que hagamos las cuentas correspondientes
para obtenerlas así que lo primero que
voy a hacer es trabajar con gaby aunque
no hay necesidad de hacerlo porque ya lo
tenemos todo aquí así como disponemos
esta información mejor nos vamos a mover
la pantalla y vamos a trabajar con
alfredo este es el pp l nuevo para el
freno y ahora sí que nos dice esta
gráfica que tenemos aquí dice si alfredo
gasta todo su tiempo obtiene 40 tazas
ahora bien si alfredo gastará todo su
tiempo en obtener platos va a obtener
40 platos eso no está diciendo que
tenemos este cuadrado que tengo aquí voy
a dibujarlo con una línea punteada y
ahora vamos a sacar sus respectivos
costes de oportunidad primero para
platos 40 platos es igual a 40 tazas y
bueno si divido a ambos lados entre 40
pues eso es muy sencillo me queda que un
plato es igual a una taza y ya con esto
obtengo el coste de oportunidad para un
plato y los padres que como esto es una
igualdad puedo voltearlo y decir que
pues una taza es lo mismo que un plato y
por lo tanto también ya tengo el costo
de oportunidad de tazas una taza
entonces va a ser igual a un plato y
recuerden que estamos suponiendo las
mismas entradas por lo tanto se dan
cuenta
alfredo le está yendo bastante bien pues
alfredo tiene una ventaja absoluta mayor
en platos y en tazas a comparación de
gabi bueno esperen sin embargo si nos
fijamos en las ventajas comparativas
fíjense que pasa algo muy curioso porque
en este caso alfredo produce un plato
por una taza mientras que gaby sigue
produciendo un plato por un tercio de
taza por lo tanto casi sigue obteniendo
una ventaja comparativa en plato
a comparación de alfredo alfredo sigue
necesitando más tasas o más de taza para
obtener un plato que lo que gasta gabi
un tercio de taza es menor que una taza
y por lo tanto hay una gran diferencia
eso le da a gabi esta ventaja
comparativa en platos a comparación
alfredo ahora si pensamos en tazas y nos
damos cuenta que alfredo produce una
taza por un plato y de hecho es un poco
mayor a lo que producía antes antes
producía una taza por un tercio de plato
y ahora produce una taza por un plato
entero aumentó su productividad pero
también aumentó el coste de producción y
bueno hay muchas formas de ver esto
aunque pese a ello yo creo que es
bastante bueno el aumentar tu
productividad lo que sí les puedo decir
y lo que quiero que vean es que alfredo
tiene una ventaja comparativa en tazas a
comparación de está gaby porque gabi
obtiene una taza por tres platos
mientras que alfredo obtiene una taza
por un plato y por lo tanto esto le da
una ventaja comparativa alfredo a
comparación de gabi y bueno eso nos hace
pensar que en este pp l de alfredo
podemos hacer que alfredo se especialice
solamente en tazas
y se especializa solamente en platos y
que comercien y aún así vamos a obtener
un gran beneficio de ambos porque la
idea que hay detrás de comerciales que
saquen un provecho de los dos entonces
fíjense que aquí está el pp l de alfredo
y si alfredo gasta todo su tiempo en
obtener tazas entonces lo que va a
producir son 40 tazas mientras que si
gavi se especializa solamente en platos
entonces va a gastar todo su tiempo en
hacer platos iba a obtener 30 platos por
la cantidad de tiempo que habíamos
fijado que recuerdo que era como un día
y recuerden también de que estamos
hablando de que las entradas son iguales
por lo tanto qué va a pasar aquí pues es
hora de ponerlos a comerciar y qué es lo
que les va a convenir a ambos para
comerciar fijémonos primero en gavín
gabi está haciendo 30 platos en este
tiempo determinado y por lo tanto ella
va a necesitar tazas y lo que va a
querer hacer es comerciar con sus platos
para obtener tasas sin embargo ella
obtiene por una taza tres platos eso es
lo que dice en su costo de oportunidad y
por lo tanto ella lo que va a querer es
comerciar algo menor a este coste de
oportunidad porque si no pues no tendría
caso comercial
tanto gaby va a querer comerciar y vamos
a suponer que gaby lo que quieres son
una tasa no sabe lo que va a querer es
comerciar dos platos por una taza me
parece bien dos platos por una taza
ahora hay que pensar en el fred o va a
querer alfredo como el ser también por
esa cantidad pero bueno ahorita nos
vamos con alfredo porque primero antes
que nada porque gabi está obteniendo dos
platos por una taza lo que hace que
mejore su coste de oportunidad por lo
tanto a gabi le conviene comercial y por
lo tanto gaby saque una mayor ventaja y
ella se puede concentrar completamente
en hacer platos y entonces saca un
beneficio de comercial con alfredo y
ahora vamos a pensar en alfredo alfredo
le conviene este precio
alfredo obtiene una taza por un plato y
aquí le van a dar dos platos por una
taza es decir que si le conviene le van
a dar el doble por cada taza
por lo tanto alfredo va a decir claro
que me comida comercial yo también
quiero comerciar con gaby y vamos a
hacer el trato y ahora vamos a ver todo
esto en números vamos a suponer que
alfredo bueno como produce 40 tazas
suponer que dar 20 tazas para comerciar
con gaby entonces alfredo está pensando
en comerciar con gaby y lo que quieren
comerciar son 20 tazas y esperen
este es un mal ejemplo ya se dieron
cuenta porque lo que pasa es que a gabi
no le va a alcanzar 20 por dos platos
serían 40 platos no a gabino de alcance
este es un mal ejemplo pongamos otro
supongamos que alfredo en lugar de dar
20 tazas va a dar 10 tazas y por lo
tanto alfredo se queda con 30 tazas
entonces le bajó 10 y ahora sí se puede
porque 10 por 2 son 20 tazas y vamos a
escribirlo aquí alfredo va a comerciar
con gaby 10 tazas y bueno por lo tanto
va a obtener 20 platos a cambio según el
trato que habían hecho van a dar por
cada taza dos platos y entonces ahora
alfredo está situado justo en este punto
tiene 30 tazas y 20 platos por lo tanto
estamos en este punto de aquí y esto
está genial porque estamos arriba de la
línea pp l
alfredo está sacando por lo tanto una
ventaja de comerciar con gaby y se dan
cuenta este punto además de estar arriba
de la línea de pepe l además nos indica
que es una ventaja que no puede obtener
ninguna otra forma más que comerciando
con gaby y bueno lo máximo que puede
obtener a las 30 tazas de gabi por lo
tanto estamos hasta acá y tenemos la
línea punteada que voy a dibujar aquí es
esta línea que estoy dibujando justo
aquí y bueno ahora pensemos qué es lo
que va a pasar para gaby gabi va a tener
que dar 20 platos pero va a obtener a
cambio 10 tazas por lo tanto va a estar
situada en este punto que tenemos aquí
que si se dan cuenta también está arriba
de la línea de pepe l por lo tanto le
conviene tanto a gaby como alfredo
comerciar juntos